you guys absolutely rocked plague inc
the videos up to 2 million views now I'm
reading your comments everybody wants me
to play bio-ink I want to play the
newest version but I don't have a PC so
let's go bio-ink iPhone now 3 2 1 John
I'm afraid I don't have very good news
for you today Oh
first of all your high blood pressure
combined with your high cholesterol led
to your severe chest pain additionally
you being a smoker and overweight but
you would risk of a heart attack or
stroke I like this game let's go alright
I apparently have to enter my internship
let's go ok choose the stage let's new
healthy name your victim oh oh man
there's so much I want to do I I'll keep
it simple for now Hitler okay we're
gonna keep it mild to start it up
alright Stage one Hitler is overweight
sedentary a junk food addict and a
smoker use these risk factors to your
advantage to upgrade your diseases and
terminate Hitler before doctors find a
cure oh my god this is like plague ink
but you're trying to kill a human let's
see what I have to do here okay bacteria
and viruses look carefully you need to
collect bacteria and viruses to earn
points select in fact this system and
tap the bacteria or virus Oh Oh got a
little upper respiratory virus in there
for days in nervous system renal system
skeletal system digestive system Oh
nervous system he's got like a learn
away get it though his renal
boom what he had a kidney infection man
hailer had a UTI
you know pneumonia now by a point you
have a few bio points tap the bio points
to spend your bio points and upgrade
your disease let's change his risk
factors
he's already overweight right listen we
don't need that we can't afford any of
these yeah
a person who is unlucky is subjected to
or marked by misfortune both Hitler is a
very unlucky person oh man you can give
them diseases that's crazy okay well
first I want to go back see ya Thursday
17 days in okay
a workaholic is a person who is addicted
to work no thank you
we're not gonna make Hillier a
workaholic malnutrition yes cuz
malnutrition is the leading killer via
the obesity epidemic evolving Hitler's
not eating properly damn Skippy we're
collecting those bio points quick
nervous system BAM dehydration occurs
when you lose more yeah dehydration and
diarrhea are the world's leading killers
so let's go evolve we're gonna get this
guy down Hitler's dehydrated why am I
getting so happy about killing somebody
granted it's Hitler so that makes it
okay obese yeah we're gonna make him
obese oh man he's gonna be unhealthy
he's smoking his obese he's got all the
risk factors I wanted to be morbidly
obese
okay hereditary yeah we want him to have
hereditary illness Hitler has been
fledged with poor genes ha can I feel so
evil let's give him some diseases let's
go right to the respiratory tract and
give him oh wow
24 bronchitis flu
it's Gitmo food oh you caught a very bad
flu now let's see if I can double that
up and see if I can get him a bronchitis
and a flu at the same time oh he's sick
you hear him coughing well look at his
respiratory system failing he's getting
muscle damage his kidneys are about to
start failing
oh emphysema oh my god he has bronchitis
flu and emphysema Oh visit to the doctor
he's going to visit the doctor he will
investigate hope it's not a good doctor
it took him 22% of his respiratory
function to decrease for Hitler to go
see the doctor what a lazy bum
pneumothorax you know what that means
when his lung collapses yep Oh be
careful doctors are treating Hitler
achieve your objective before the
recovery progress reaches 100% our
Hitler will live I will not let that
happen he's only at 6% recovery I'm good
he can't recover he has one lung and he
has like three infections emphysema
bronchitis flu h1n1 swine flu hit him he
has a regular flu swine flu emphysema a
collapsed lung pneumothorax this guy
ain't surviving look at that I'm hitting
him with the pneumonia it's impossible
he can't survive he's a 19% new oh look
at his lung function he's dying
there's no way pneumonia h1n1 flu
bronchitis emergency room in critical
condition Hiller has been admitted to
the ER doctors are now intensifying
their efforts to save him oh no they're
healing him no way he's at 2%
no way systems failure
Hitler systems are failing increased
failure rate by terminating other
symptoms what he can't live without his
lungs nurses on strike honestly a
hospital can't function without nurses
and this is gonna be proof right here
with Hitler Hitler
Hitler's bones are very weak he's got
rickets there's no way he's gonna
survive if he has multi organ failure
it's game over for Hitler oh my god
they're speeding up his healing let me
do something bad muscular dystrophy or
potassium deficiency and deficiency
because I'll make his heart go bad two
chronic muscle pain that's not that good
I like muscular dystrophy
he's more susceptible to damage that way
both his muscular system and his
respiratory systems have failed oh let's
give him high cholesterol and
hypertension oh my god good luck Hitler
good luck all right all his systems are
failing all right everything failed come
on now yes Hitler died in 271 days time
of death February 20 cause of death
pneumothorax I never thought I'd be
proud at least this proud to kill a
patient although if it was Hitler I
still couldn't do it my Hippocratic oath
wouldn't allow me to but I'm still
really happy in this game I we're going
for round two this game hits a little
close to home
compared to plague inc because plague
inc you're like infecting countries it's
a little bit more distant here I feel
like I'm being a bad doctor and actually
killing my patient for some reason it
feels kind of good
let's do moderate difficulty I don't
want it too hard I know more Hitler Ted
Bundy if you watch our documentary on
Netflix by the way it's crazy the Bundy
tapes Ted Bundy is overweight sedentary
and junk food addict and a smoker use
these risk factors to your advantage you
know I think I might just go for the
circulatory system failure because that
makes everything fair there's something
rewarding about collecting these little
viruses as they
but like a dopamine hit each time I pop
up like poop oh let's make him obese
whoa Ted Bundy she you now obese my
friend ooh Ted Bundy has a UTI someone
just overhears me like in the next room
doctor Mike's giving Ted Bundy a UTI
what can we make him morbidly obese yeah
I'm gonna get him all his risk factors
oh how appropriate Ted Bundy is about to
have unprotected sexual relations you
get a chance to spin the wheel of STDs
I'm ready
spin the wheel Oh HPV that's not ever
that's had HPV infection causes warts
more than a hundred varieties of human
papilloma virus exists it's dangerous in
the throat dangerous in the cervix for
women but outside of that it's not that
exciting and it's a long-term problem I
want him to suffer now I'm gonna make
sure that he has the worst risk factors
for survival and then hit him with the
symptoms Oh night Oh malnutrition and
hereditary he doesn't even have a
disease yet and he's already falling
apart look at that Ted Bundy you've done
wrong by me by the way fun fact Ted
Bundy was the first televised murder
trial look at that I'm just full of fun
facts today look being over 60 years old
increases disease damages that's true
you hear him he's suffering a little bit
I don't even know why I just made him
older and unhealthy oh gee hydration yes
and allergies allergies are the over
activation of the immune system as soon
as I turn on the disease then I'm gonna
infect them with it's probably gonna be
circulatory he's going down Oh Ted
Bundy's going to a doctor for his annual
checkup all right Ted Bundy you smart
you smart but let's see what the doctors
gonna do to you because right now you
don't have any diseases because I got a
Doctorate degree then I know how to kill
Ted Bundy be careful doctors are
treating him treating him with what he's
not sick they're treating him fairly
quickly I don't like this Oh
all medications are now poisonous on Ted
Bundy they don't know what that means
that's not real medicine risk factors
drug addict yep he had every risk factor
in the books
okay watch this I'm 190 days in it took
a while to develop all of these issues
but watch how quickly I'm gonna take
down his heart most people don't know
that but if you take down the heart
everything else will follow because
blood doesn't circulate it's called
shock you have many types of shock
cardiogenic shock when the heart doesn't
beat septic shock when it's due to an
infectious source see that we're
learning we're gonna give him
hypertension and we're gonna give him
high cholesterol angina
oh yeah he's having chest pain all right
Angela's chest pain from a lack of
circulation to the heart ah not bad
doctors not all doctors are good some
are too busy to work slow yep and a
circulatory system is failing
what disease and china has been cured
that's ridiculous man oh my god he's
been admitted to the emergency room with
only 15% of the circulation that's not
bad
wait he's feeling way too quick I won't
be able to stop this no way I mean he
should he should die fairly quickly here
Ted Bundy's under a lot of stress yeah
his body's dying
nervous systems at 4645 oh man it's
tight I'm gonna try and just kill him
right now
chronic stress yes nervous breakdown
yes oh my god it's coming to the water
let's see if I could stop the recovery
oh nice I think I think I got him right
there I think that was the move I think
that was the move I his nervous system
failed now everything should start
failing all right let's give him some
asthma oh my god he's a 91% but
everything is failing all right three
organs have failed him come on he can't
keep going like this muscular what can I
give him potassium deficiency that's
gonna for sure and him for sure oh my
God look how tight it is look how tight
it is yes oh I got way too excited Ted
Bundy died in 411 days bear did you hear
that
come here we kill Ted Bundy together we
did it together bad good job good job I
couldn't have done it without you my
little youth although you're not that
little okay thanks well that was tight
here is I got 98% cure but then right
away his systems failed I think it goes
on hard I would have to choose a
different strategy I've bear here in my
mouth sorry
I think plague Inc is a little bit more
evolved in this one although this is the
free version and I think if I play the
desktop PC version if you want me to do
that drop it down below in the comments
I want to do that for sure i justa find
a PC somewhere but I'm game something I
must encourage you to do is a few days
from now on Sunday at 11 a.m.
watch my 30 days of vegan video it's a
must but for now enjoy this playlist
right here I'll be playing some games
operation play a game surgery simulator
whisper challenge even overwatch and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]